How deep does this thing go?
Picture this: You’re sailing along the Grand
Line, minding your own business, just straight
up chilling.
When suddenly, you spot it: An Ice Berg.[Show
Ice Berg the One Piece Character]
No, not Ice Berg the shipwright.
This ice berg is no simple character.
This is the ONE PIECE ICE BERG.
Embedded inside its icy walls are the greatest
mysteries and theories of the series.
So hop in the Polar Tang [Show Law’s submarine]
and let’s plumb the depths to find out how
far down the One Piece fandom goes.
Come with us on our journey to explore the
wildest theories the internet has to offer.
Toby Hook:
Let’s talk about One Piece Ice Berg.
No NOT the character!
The ice berg that contains the greatest mysteries
and theories in one piece!
I’ve seen a lot of videos breaking down
icebergs for different topics, but as far
as I know none about One Piece.
In case you don’t know, the ice berg video
format is a system of levels starting with
popular and mainstream theories & mysteries
of a certain topic, the tip of the ice berg
everyone knows, and then moving deeper towards
the wildest and darkest theories the internet
has to offer.
Starting with Tier 1.
**TIER 1**
**Crocodile was born a woman.**
Rising above the surface of the waters, we
have a couple tier 1 theories that you’ve
probably heard of before.
Like the theory that Crocodile was assigned
female at birth.
Sir Crocodile, the first Shichibukai that
Luffy took down, remains to this day one of
the fandom’s favorite villains in the entire
manga.
His cunning plans, awesome sand powers, and
an unforgettable laugh [use Croc’s laugh
sound here] make him stand high above more
dangerous foes, even if he was defeated by
a pre-timeskip Luffy.
But the leader of Baroque Works - Mr. 0, if
you will - has a secret even more secret that
his own identity.
Moreover, the knowledge of this secret is
known to one Emporio Ivankov, the ruler of
the Kamabakka Queendom.
And just what secret would the holder of the
hormone fruit be privy to?
Well, that Crocodile was born biologically
female and then thanks to Ivankov’s powers,
physically transitioned to become male.
In other words, Crocodile is a trans man.
After all, Oda’s drawing of a young Crocodile
is gender ambiguous.
**Admirals vs. Monster Trio**
The Marines have three very strong military
forces.
The Straw Hats have three very strong pirates.
They will fight.
Or so the story went before Akainu earned
a promotion and Aokiji went off to hang with
Blackbeard.
However, that’s not going to stop fans from
speculating who the final matchups will be
when it comes time for the Straw Hats to take
on the strongest Marine powers.
Luffy has it out for Akainu, obviously.
Sanji’s kicks will have to stack up against
Kizaru’s lightspeed kicks.
Zoro and Fujitora both have swords - a match
made in heaven.
Hmmm…and what about Greenbull?
Well, we just learned that Aramaki is a highly
prejudiced individual and we happen to have
the powerful Fishman/Civil Rights advocate,
Jinbe, on the crew.
It’s not much a monster trio anymore, but
we’re looking forward to the Admirals vs.
the Monster Quartet.
**One Piece was the Friends we Made Along
the Way**
What is the One Piece?
Well, the greatest fear among the fans is
that the One Piece…is nothing.
There is not treasure - no world shaking revelations.
Like the old saying goes - Life is a journey,
not a destination.
Finding the One Piece was never about material
gain.
That’s why all of the treasure seekers who
only sought riches were doomed to fail, but
the adventurous Luffy and his crew who only
wanted freedom will be the ones to attain
it.
The *real* treasure was the adventures they
had and all of the friends they made.
Hmm… now that I think about it, the treasure
being nothing actually fits really well thematically.
But thankfully Oda Sensei has gone on record
saying that the One Piece *is* a physical,
tangible treasure.
So thank goodness, the cop-out ending has
been avoided and we’re getting something
cool and shiny in a few years!
**Dragon Wind Logia**
Normal absentee fathers go out to buy milk.
*Real* absentee fathers go out to wage war
against an oppressive government.
When Luffy finally met *his* absentee father
in Loguetown, he was accompanied by a powerful
gale that enabled the Straw Hats’ escape
from Captain Smoker.
This very convenient wind (tinged green in
the anime) seemed almost supernaturally fortunate.
Well, our best guess is that while the winds
were supernatural - they weren’t supernaturally
lucky - they were just supernatural in the
sense that they were the result of Dragon’s
devil fruit power, which is likely a Wind
or Storm fruit.
After all, this revolutionary who wants to
overturn the status quo could be said to bring
the “winds of change” - we all know Oda’s
up for some good wordplay after all.
**Zoro is from Wano**
This popular theory is *pretty* much confirmed.
Zoro was from an island named after the Shimotsuki
clan.
He definitely has some lineage here, but what
we would still love some answers on is who
exactly he’s descended from.
He looks exactly like the former Daimyo of
the Shimotsuki, Ushimaru.
However, Oda has gone out of his way in an
SBS to deny that Zoro is Ushimaru’s son
despite very directly and obviously hinting
at it in the manga.
So is he a nephew?
A grandson?
Just tell us who he is, Oda, we’re begging
you!
**Carrot for Nakama**
People seem to think that the hope for this
rabbit mink joining the crew is dead in the
water.
She didn’t stow away when the crew left
Wano, shirking her responsibility as the new
ruler of Zou.
Instead, Caribou was in the barrel.
Oda even played with our hearts and mocked
us by having the Sunny use a special new technique
- the rabbit screw, in which the ship is propelled
by a barrel-housed propeller that looks like
a rabbit.
But did you even consider this?
Yeah, sure Caribou is in the barrel, but you
know what?
Caribou can also fit a lot of barrels inside
him.
And what’s in those barrels?
Carrot, probably.
I will not give up hope that Carrot is still
stowed away inside of Caribou’s swamp until
we get a direct refutation of this theory.
Never give up on Carrot because she’ll never
give up on you.
**Sanji is a Prince**
Give yourselves a round of applause One Piece
fans.
You got this one right!
Before the Whole Cake Island arc, tons of
fans predicted that Sanji would turn out to
be a prince.
All the way back in the Baroque Works saga,
he assumed the secret identity: Mr. Prince.
The theory went that this was more than a
nickname - this “secret identity” held
a big secret after all.
In actuality, Sanji was a prince.
Later, we received news that Sanji was actually
from North Blue and had somehow ended up in
the East Blue with Zeff.
During the confrontation with Kuma, Sanji
revealed that he’d be the one to cause the
Straw Hats the most trouble down the line.
There was the running gag that every single
one of Sanji’s wanted posters didn’t actually
show his face for one reason or another.
However, in Dressrosa as soon as Sanji’s
real face was shown, his bounty condition
was changed to “Only Alive”, proving that
he was connected to someone with a lot of
power in the One Piece world.
Finally, we learned that Sanji was in fact
a prince of the Germa Kingdom, proving many
eagle-eyed fans 100% correct.
**Garp is the leader of SWORD**
SWORD is a secret organization within the
Marines with the aim of making the Marines
a force for good in the world instead of a
force for propping up the Celestial Dragons.
Since two of the prominently known members
of SWORD are Koby and Helmeppo, who notably
trained directly under Monkey D. Garp, logic
would follow that Garp is the secret leader
of the organization.
**7 Moons**
We know that Minks turn Sulong under the full
moon and that Enel is chilling out on a moon
- but a more important question is…which
one?
In the Library of Ohara, we can see a model
of the One Piece planet and its orbiting satellites
that clearly show seven moons.
If this is the case, does the world still
have all of these moons or were some destroyed
somehow.
Or do we just conveniently never see more
than one in the sky at once?
Hopefully the scientific mastermind Vegapunk
drops some moon knowledge on us very soon.**Enel’s
Return**
And speaking of moons - Enel is up to something
on the moon.
In his cover story he reached “Fairy Vearth”
and found the ruins of an ancient civilization
that seem to hold illustrations of the Ancient
Weapons.
He also used his devil fruit to power up a
bunch of long dormant automatons.
All this, and he also even met bonafide space
pirates.
So clearly, Enel is going to play into the
story again somehow, as so many cover story
characters do.
So how exactly are the Straw Hats going to
encounter this God again?
Is he going to strike down back to earth with
a robot army?
Or are the Strawhats - much like Gamestop
Stock - going to the MOON!?
**Tenth Titanic Captain Aokiji**The Blackbeard
Pirates have Ten Titanic Captains, but we
have yet to find out who the tenth is.
So far we only know of 9 Blackbeard crew members
(plus Blackbeard himself, but since Burgess
is the 1st captain, Teach doesn’t factor
into the count).
There have been a lot of wild guesses for
who this final Blackbeard crew member could
be, but the prevailing theory is the former
Marine Admiral Aokiji.
Seeing Kuzan go fully onto the Blackbeard
crew and abandon his sense of justice is a
wild idea, but we do know that Aokiji is currently
allied with them in some capacity.
Having him on their side would also hugely
increase the stakes when it’s finally time
for the Straw Hats to fight their crew.
**Monster Point-Awakened Zoan**
It’s heavily implied that the Impel Down
jailers are Awakened Zoans.
If that’s so, they’d be the first awakened
devil fruit users that we ever saw in the
series.
UNLESS there’s actually one we saw first
- and wouldn’t you know it, they were actually
a member of the Straw Hat crew.
Chopper ingesting three rumble balls might
have triggered a forced Zoan awakening.
Monster Point may in fact have been the first
devil fruit awakening we ever saw in the series.
**TIER 2**
All of this - and we haven’t even scratched
the surface.
You probably know all of these theories and
easter eggs already.
But now get ready to hold your breath because
we’re diving down to see what the One Piece
Iceberg holds in Tier 2.
**Shanks Davy Back Fight**
Among One Piece’s “so-called fans” there
are lots of people who think the Davy Back
Fight and the Long-Ring-Long-Land arc are
boring and unimportant.
Real fans, of course, believe in Foxy supremacy.
We also know that Oda-Sensei doesn’t have
any unimportant arcs - just look at all of
the Skypiea deniers now.
So how will the Davy Back Fight play into
the story again?
Well, when it comes time for Shanks and Luffy
to finally meet again, this theory has it
the Roger and Luffy - the former and the future
pirate king.
The straw hat belonged to Roger.
They share the same secret dream.
So why not the same devil fruit?
This long-held theory believed that the former
owner of the Gomu-Gomu no Mi was none other
than Gol D. Roger.
However, Kaidou’s recent statement that
Roger didn’t have any devil fruit powers
seems to disprove this theory.
We can say goodbye for our hopes for a stretchy
Roger.
**Usopp’s Lies Come True**
The pirates attacking Syrup Village.
The Giant Goldfish.
A huge mole.
[Miss Merry Christmas] A beautiful swordsman
with meat.
[Rebecca].
Usopp has told many lies throughout the series
and one theory holds that by the end of the
story all of these lies will come true.
If that’s the case…are they really lies?
One major lie we still need to see come true?
Usopp leading an army 8000 strong.
We got close in Dressrosa, but we still need
to pump up those numbers so let’s cross
our fingers for Elbaf.
**Kuina=Tashigi**
Zoro’s childhood friend, Kuina, was the
catalyst for his dream.
Every day that he strives to accomplish his
dream of becoming the world’s greatest swordsman,
he does it because of the promise he made
to her.
However, what if she wasn’t dead after all?
What if, after losing her memories, she actually
grew up to become his marine rival Tashigi,
the secondhand to Smoker?
It wouldn’t be Oda’s first time using
amnesia as a plot point: looking at you Big
Mom and Sabo.
After all, Tashigi looks just like Kuina and
has a similar love of swords.
Is it a coincidence or is there more to the
story?
**Luffy will get Roger’s Disease**
Before Roger’s execution, he was diagnosed
with an incurable disease.
In the ongoing list of things that Luffy has
inherited from Roger, will he, too, contract
“PirateKing-Itis”?
Will the story end just like it began - with
the death of a pirate king?
We have, after all, gotten lots and lots of
hints throughout the story about Luffy shortening
his life span.
Gear 2nd shortens his life span.
His adrenaline treatments from Ivankov shortened
his life span.
A side effect of Gear 5 appeared to be temporarily
transforming into an old man.
Will this spell the end for Luffy?
Is this exertion related to the incurable
disease that Roger had?
Good thing the Thousand Sunny’s doctor has
a goal of curing every disease in the world.
**Roger’s Egg**
In many flashbacks we can see a massive egg
incubating on the back of Roger’s ship,
the Oro Jackson.
What could have hatched from a huge egg?
Was it Marco?
A dragon?
Was it related to the ancient weapon Uranus?
Could the One Piece be the world’s largest
omelet?
Many theories have *hatched* from this giant
egg.
The most likely theory?
It was simply Tamago taking a nap.
**Luffy 5,600,000,000**
In Japanese, Gomu means rubber or gum - as
in the Gomu Gomu no Mi.
However, the words Go-Mu can also be read
as the number 56.
Therefore, Oda has long associated the number
56 with Luffy.
As a child, he’s seen wearing a shirt with
the number 56 on it.
Lucy’s coliseum number was 0556.
There are 56 members of the Barto Fan Club.
The Grand Fleet numbers over 5,600.
Since Roger’s final bounty was revealed
to be a little over 5.5 billion, this theory
predicts that Luffy’s final bounty will
surpass Roger’s and also keep with the theme
of Luffy being associated with the number
56.
He’ll likely have a final bounty of 5.6
billion berries.
**Immortality Surgery**
In Dressrosa, we learned that Law’s Ope-Ope
no Mi has a special ability.
In exchange for the user’s life, they can
perform the immortality surgery, making their
target immortal.
We don’t have much additional information
about the exact mechanics of this insane ability,
but this doesn’t seem like the thing that
Oda - king of foreshadowing - would casually
drop and then never bring up again.
Forget Chekhov’s Gun - this is Chekhov’s
Nuke.
As for who Law may end up sacrificing his
life for, it’s a mystery.
Doflamingo wanted Law to use it on him, but
with the former Shichibukai locked up, it’s
a good bet it’ll be someone else.
Though, we don’t think Doflamingo will be
in Impel Down forever.
Did a past user use this surgery on seemingly
ancient characters like Imu or the Gorosei?
Will Law use it on Luffy to circumvent the
side effects of the aforementioned PirateKing-Itis?
Or will someone more nefarious use it?
Blackbeard’s confrontation with Law has
us worried…
**Usopp Conqueror’s Haki**
Usopp is the ultimate underdog in One Piece.
In a world of super-powered beings, he’s
someone that us normal weakling humans can
really relate to.
However, in addition to his insane stamina
and pain tolerance [show his skull being shattered
by Mr. 4], he’s also been shown to have
some incredible feats.
Namely, he unlocked observation haki when
he stopped Sugar from transforming Luffy and
Law into toys on Dressrosa.
Usopp’s ultimate goal is to become a brave
warrior of the sea and he’s teased leading
armies 8,000 soldiers strong.
While he does seem to be a fearful coward,
he’s courageous in that he always overcomes
his fear to take on opponents many times stronger
than himself.
That sounds like a conqueror to me - so maybe
Usopp will join Luffy and Zoro as a member
of the Straw Hats that can use the rarest
form of Haki.
**The Straw** **Hat is the One Piece**
What is the One Piece?
It’s not the friends we made along the way.
That would just be silly.
Obviously, it’s the great treasure that
Luffy has had all along.
As far back as Orange Town, after Buggy stabbed
through the straw hat, we learned that it
was Luffy’s most prized possession - his
treasure.
How then, could even finding Roger’s treasure
- the One Piece - surpass the treasure Luffy’s
always had.
But this theory works more than just on a
metaphorical level.
What if the straw hat is genuinely important.
We know that the hat passed from Roger to
Shanks to Luffy.
We also know that Imu-Sama has a massive straw
hat in cold storage.
Somehow the hat is obviously connected to
the ancient history and the void century,
so is it going too far to think that the hat
is the One Piece itself?
**Scopper visited Crocus**
Once upon a time in a fateful cover story
that would spawn theory after theory, we were
treated to everyone’s favorite whale doctor,
Crocus, chatting it up with a mysterious figure.
The figure was dressed in an Amigasa straw
hat and Wano-style robes, giving the impression
that this character would be connected to
Wano.
However, the Wano arc came and went with no
reveal to speak of.
Since Crocus was the doctor for the Roger
pirates, one leading idea for the identity
for this character is none other than Scopper
Gaban.
After other former Roger pirates like Rayleigh
have become important players in the story,
it seems like it would only make sense to
introduce Scopper into the story.
He’s featured prominently in many of the
Roger flashbacks, but we still haven’t met
him in the current timeline.
At this rate, will we ever meet Roger’s
3rd in command?
**Admiral Koby**It’s unlikely that Akainu
will promote Koby to become one of the highest
military powers.
And besides - pink isn’t on the color wheel,
so how would Koby possibly fit in with the
current naming conventions of the admirals.
He doesn’t even have an uber-powerful logia
devil fruit, either.However, Koby’s dream
is to become a Marine Admiral.
By the end of the series, he will.
One Piece is a series where characters we
love achieve their dreams.
If the end of the series sees a reformation
of the Marines to become a true force for
justice in the world, SWORD will likely lead
that transformation.
And with them, Koby may become one of the
leaders of the Marines.
**Zunisha is Pluton**
In Fishman Island, we learned that the ancient
weapon Poseidon was not a physical object,
but a living person.
Unlike Pluton, which we’d heard was a warship,
Poseidon was actually the mermaid princess
Shirahoshi and her power to control the Sea
Kings.
In Wano, we learned that Pluton is actually
housed beneath Wano.
However, we haven’t laid eyes on it yet.
Perhaps the real story is more complicated
and Momonosuke’s ability to communicate
with and command the giant elephant Zunisha
is somehow connected with the ancient weapon
Pluton.
**Devil Fruits are Man Made**
Dr. Vegapunk and Caesar Clown’s SMILE technology
has allowed the criminal underworld to produce
artificial devil fruits.
Most of them are pale reflections of a true
devil fruit’s capabilities, and many of
them are outright defective.
However, what if *all* devil fruits are actually
artificial.
What if these magic fruits are actually scientific
creations of the Ancient Kingdom?
Perhaps devil fruits didn’t just occur as
a byproduct of nature, but were specifically
cultivated and created to imbue great powers
upon those who eat the fruits.
When Vegapunk cracked the code to recreating
Kaidou’s fruit, he wasn’t imitating nature,
but recreating an ancient technology.
**Weevil is Whitebeard’s Real Son**
When we were first introduced to Edward Weevil,
the only Shichibukai who didn’t get to accomplish
a single thing in the story before the Warlord
system was disbanded, we had a lot of thoughts.
Thoughts such as “what is this guy’s deal”
and “there’s no way this clown is Whitebeard’s
son.”
Oda, however, likes to write his story in
a way that keeps us constantly surprised.
What would the most surprising reveal be in
relation to Weevil?
Well, that this wasn’t a lie after all.
Mr. Newgate - you are the father.
[including a snippet of Maury might be fun
here]
**TIER 3**
Oh, are these theories not enough for you?
Well we’re only just now getting started.
We’ve stuck our heads under the water and
now it’s time to start swimming because
we’ve arrived at Tier 3.
**The Raid will Fail**
Viewers of a certain Mr. Morj will be familiar
with this theory.
Once upon a time, fans hoped for a 5 act structure
to the Wano arc.
However as Act 3 stretched on longer…and
longer…and longer…it became evident that
we were in the climax of the arc.
The theory went based on the 5 act structure
of many Kabuki plays, which says that at the
end of the 3rd act there’s a great tragedy,
followed by a final battle in act 4 and a
resolution in act 5.
We kept waiting for our great tragedy - We
thought perhaps the Scabbards’ defeat by
Kaidou would be the tragedy.
We thought that maybe Luffy being thrown into
the sea was the tragedy.
We thought that Luffy’s literal death was
the tragedy.
The idea, popularized and the meme-ified by
Mr. Morj’s channel, was that after a loss
during the raid, the allies would have to
recoup their losses and then train to fight
another day before ultimately beating Kaidou.
However, in the end, Oda once again defied
our expectations.
**Mythical Cerberus Zoan**
Blackbeard always works in threes.
He has three skulls on his flag.
He has three pistols.
He left three scars on Shanks’ face.
This popular theory says that in addition
to his Darkness Logia and Earthquake Paramecia
fruit, Blackbeard has a third fruit: one that
allows him to have three different devil fruits
in the first place.
He has a mythical dog zoan: Model Cerberus.
This three headed dog of legend just works
too well for the “three” motif that Blackbeard
has going for him.
**Law is in SWORD**
This is another theory that’s part of a
specific YouTuber’s agenda.
This idea was popularized by Randy Troy.
Law may be playing the long con, being a secret
marine all along.
It would mean that he takes after his mentor,
Rosinante, like so many other One Piece characters
who also take after their mentors.
This secret identity would also make sense
given the interactions between X-Drake, another
SWORD member, and Law on Wano.
Their cryptic conversation seemed to reveal
a sort of connection.
Another piece of evidence for the theory deals
with the mysterious Rocky Port incident, which
gave Law the reputation to become a Shichibukai,
and in which Koby, another SWORD member, played
the hero.
**Straw Hat Devil Fruit**
For those of you who were not weekly during
Dressrosa, this may surprise you.
When the Mera-Mera no Mi was up for grabs
there was no shortage of theories for who
would receive the fruit.
Some theories were Sanji, who had already
been seen to use flames, or even Franky…for
some reason.
Sabo hadn’t yet re-entered the story and
there was no telling when or if this other
brother would return.
There were even many theories that an antagonist
would eat the fruit, leading to Luffy having
to fight against his brother’s fruit.However,
one of the wildest speculations to come out
of this time was that Luffy’s Straw Hat
would get a devil fruit.
Luffy himself, of course, couldn’t eat the
fruit since he’d already eaten the Gomu
Gomu no Mi.
However, ever since Alabasta we’ve known
that inanimate objects are able to consume
devil fruits.
This led a ton of people to believe that the
Straw Hat would gain the power to become fire,
allowing Luffy and Ace to continue fighting
alongside each other in a way.
But hey, who knows, maybe it’s not too late
for the Straw Hat to get another fruit.
**Vegapunk Revolutionary**
Why would Kuma, a revolutionary, willingly
let Vegapunk turn him into a mindless machine
that does the bidding of the world government.
According to this theory, it’s because Vegapunk
has always been playing both sides of the
conflict.
While they’re happy to accept the government’s
research and development funding, they may
not agree politically with the government’s
aims.
They might, in fact, want to use their technology
to make the world a better place and only
make weapons in a trade-off that allows them
to fund the research they really want to do.
It’s possible that Kuma still retains some
of his old will.
After all, before going full Pacifista he
was able to send the Straw Hats to their timeskip
destinations as well as guarding the Thousand
Sunny.
Surely we’ll learn more about Vegapunk’s
allegiances during the Egghead Island arc.
**The D is for Dawn**
Monkey D. Luffy.
Portgas D. Ace.
Jaguar D. Saul.
Those with the D initial are the natural enemy
of God.
The Celestial Dragons fear these members of
the D clan.
But, what exactly does the D stand for?
Destiny?
Destruction?
Death?
Despair?
Delirium?
Desire?
Dream?
[Gaiman’s Sandman reference] Well, no, it’s
probably not one of the seven endless - it’s
the wrong series for that.
Instead, we should look to the original One
Piece one shot…and the title of the first
chapter of the series: Romance Dawn.
Luffy, the new JoyBoy, is foretold to bring
a new Dawn of the World, so what likelier
candidate than this for Luffy’s middle name?
**Con D. Oriano**
A lesser known member of the D clan and one
of the strongest in the verse is, of course,
Con D. Oriano.
Much like how Trafalgar D. Waterlaw hid his
true name under the guise of Trafalgar Law,
Con D. Oriano hid his D initial by going by
the name Condoriano.
For those unaware, Con D. Oriano is a member
of the Straw Hat crew that made his first
appearance in the G-8 arc - the only anime
filler arc that might as well be canon according
to the fandom.
This mighty member of the D clan single handedly
saved the Straw Hats and enabled them to escape
the G-8 base by bravely allowing himself to
be imprisoned while Robin went on an espionage
mission.
Will Oda ever make Condoriano manga canon?
We can only hope so.
**Shanks Celestial Dragon**
This red-haired Yonkou is hiding something
big.
What kind of pirate is allowed to just waltz
into the Gorosei’s chambers to hold a private
meeting?
Well, the kind that is secretly a Celestial
Dragon.
This longtime theory states that Shanks is
more than just a friendly, party-loving mentor
to Luffy.
Instead, he has a more mysterious and sinister
past as a member of the Tenryubito.
The timeline would suggest that Shanks was
an infant and would have come aboard Roger’s
ship right around the time of God Valley,
so it’s very likely that he was “adopted”
by Roger and was a survivor of that island’s
disappearance.
**Big Mom and Beast Pirates in the Grand Fleet**
The grand fleet isn’t over yet.
Having the members of Orlumbus’s crew and
the Tontatta is one thing, but to finally
take on the World Government, the Straw Hats
might need some heavier hitters.
Enter the crews of the former Yonkou, Big
Mom and Kaidou.
On Whole Cake Island, Luffy made an ally through
his hard-fought battle with Katakuri.
The two, despite being on opposing sides,
came to recognize and respect each other deeply
as individuals.
In addition to Big Mom’s son becoming an
ally, Kaidou’s son, too, befriended Luffy.
Yamato wanted to sail away with the crew,
but remained to act as Wano’s protector
from outside forces.
With these two Yonkou’s children as allies,
it’s likely that with Big Mom and Kaidou
out of the picture, the remnants of these
crews could end up fighting on the Straw Hats’
side in the final war.
**Second Time Skip**
Especially before the revelation that was
Gear 5, it was a mystery how the Straw Hats
could ever contend with the seemingly invincible
Yonkou.
Well, how did they deal with insurmountable
foes the last time?
Through a time skip, of course.
So why not Shippuden the Straw Hats a second
time?
The real reason they didn’t go this route?
Oda couldn’t figure out how to make Franky’s
shoulders any bigger.
(Among other crew member’s body parts getting
bigger…)
**Immortal Gorosei**
A lot of characters in One Piece have flashbacks
where we can see depictions of their younger
selves.
We’re treated to younger “in their prime”
versions of older characters like Garp, Sengoku,
or Whitebeard.
And when appropriate, we see those characters
de-aged to children - we’ve seen Buggy and
Shanks as kids, among many others.
However, during Robin’s flashback we got
to see the Gorosei of approximately twenty
years ago and they look…exactly the same.
With Oda paying such good attention to the
timeline and drawing the details of characters
aging, this seems too big to just be an oversight.
The designs of the Five Elder Stars were already
old, but they have not changed even a tiny
bit over that time span.
That raises the question: Do they age at all?
Or are the Gorosei immortal and unaging?
Perhaps they are the same rulers of the World
Government that were around during the Void
Century.
**Brook is Kuzan’s Grandpa**
They both have afros and ice powers.
Need we say more?
**Tier 4**
As we sink deeper and deeper, the iceberg
only grows.
Who could have predicted that what already
seemed so massive above the surface would
contain such unseen multitudes?
Do the depths of this fandom ever end?
Our craft has reached…Tier 4.
**CrocoMom**
After Enies Lobby, Luffy learned that he has
a dad.
This dad was none other than Monkey D. Dragon,
the most wanted man in the world - another
thorn in the government’s side: Like father
like son.
However, according to popular scientific sources,
in order to be born, a Shonen protagonist
needs both a father *and* a mother.
However, we have no clue who’s Luffy’s
mom is.
Or do we???
Oda has gone on record saying that he has
drawn Luffy’s mom in the series, so who
could it be?
Is it a background revolutionary still hanging
out with Dragon?
Or is it someone we know much better: A certain
Sir Crocodile.
As we learned earlier in the iceberg, Crocodile
was very likely assigned female at birth before
crossing paths with Ivankov, a revolutionary
who would have been in proximity to Dragon.
Before his transition, could he have had a
child with Dragon?
A certain Luffy, perhaps?
**Usopp is the Narrator**
The narrator of One Piece is a curious figure.
Our greatest literary scholars have tried
to intuit the exact identity of the narrator.
At times, this person speaks of future events,
as if they are recalling the story from a
later date and thus can foreshadow what’s
to come.
A prime example of this is during the formation
of the Straw Hat Grand Fleet, when the narrator
speaks of a cataclysmic event that they’ll
one day participate in.
Is this narrator just a disembodied, omniscient
and omnipresent voice?
Or is the narrator an actual character in
the story.
This theory goes that the story of One Piece
is actually being told retroactively by Usopp.
Hopefully, this story is just a little more
truthful than the ones he usually tells.
**Charlotte Bonney**
Bonney is Kuma’s daughter.
She is a princess of the Sorbet kingdom.
We know this now, but we didn’t always.
But what we did know is that Bonney has pink
hair.
Who else has pink hair?
Charlotte Lin Lin: Big Mom herself.
After all, Lola has pink hair and ended up
being Big Mom’s daughter.
Come to think of it…we don’t know who
Bonney’s mother is.
Has Kuma been one of Big Mom’s many ex-husbands
all along?
**The Thousand Sunny is Pluton**
I know we said at the beginning of the video
that we weren’t talking about that Iceberg
[Show Iceberg the character], but for this
one we’re going to have to.
During Water 7, CP9 was searching for the
blueprints to the ancient weapon, Pluton,
a powerful warship capable of mass destruction.
They thought that Iceberg had them, but in
actuality, it was his adopted brother Franky
who had them.
In order to protect them from falling into
the wrong hands, Franky burned the blueprints
so that the government couldn’t obtain them.
Later in the arc, Franky constructed the Straw
Hats’ new ship, the Thousand Sunny.
Given Franky’s immense cyborg inventor brain,
it’s not unreasonable that he could have
memorized Pluton’s blueprints.
Could some of Pluton’s super-powerful features
have actually made it into the design of his
dream ship, the Thousand Sunny?
**Dragon is not Garp’s Son**
Both of these One Piece powerhouses hold the
Monkey family name, but one theory states
that they’re not actually blood related.
While Garp is Luffy’s grandpa and Dragon
is Luffy’s father, it’s not as clear cut
that Dragon is actually Garp’s son.
Instead, Dragon could have married into the
Monkey family and much in the way that Ace
took his mother’s last name, Dragon could
have taken his wife’s last name to hide
some part of his heritage.After all, doesn’t
Dragon’s silhouette look suspiciously like
that of Rocks D. Xebec?
**Pirate King Buggy**
Buggy D. Clown has been failing his way upwards
throughout the entire series.
He started as a lowly pirate in East Blue,
but after his arrest, Luffy’s prison break
enabled him to become one of the first pirates
to escape from Impel Down.
Thanks to taking the credit for the mass escape
as well as his status as a former Roger crew
member, he was able to elevate himself to
the lofty position of Shichibukai.
Things took a turn for the worse for Buggy
when his giant crew members left to join the
Straw Hat Grand Fleet and then the Shichibukai
system was outright dissolved.
However, thanks to the Cross Guild, he’s
now cemented his status as one of the Four
Emperors of the Sea.
If the trend continues, we could see Buggy
become a bonafide King of the Pirates - at
least temporarily.
After all, doesn’t it just feel right for
this character to be present at Laugh Tale?
He’s been alongside Luffy and has such a
history with Shanks that him being with us
in the end just seems to make sense.
Provided he doesn’t get an inconveniently
timed illness again, of course.
**Marco will become an Egg**
Marco the Phoenix can turn into a…phoenix.
Wow, his epitaph is really on the nose, huh.
Anyway, despite his cool healing prowess and
powers of flight, we still haven’t seen
this pineapple activate the most famous of
phoenix powers: he still hasn’t died and
been reborn.
In the final war, will Marco be tragically
killed, only to avoid death and resurrect
himself in the form of a brand new, far younger
Marco?We’re not satisfied with Baron Tamago
being the only character with an egg-based
transformation and we will not be satisfied
until Marco, too, dies and becomes an egg
and subsequently a tiny Marco baby.
**Will of P**
Listen, I don’t make the rules.
If you’re a One Piece character and your
name starts with the letter “P”, you don’t
get to die.
Granted, most One Piece characters don’t
get to die unless they’re in a flashback,
but this goes double for our “P” characters.
Pell sacrificing himself to save Alabasta
from a massive bomb?
No problem.
Pell eats bombs for breakfast.
Old man Pagaya, Conis’s dad, taking the
full brunt of Enel’s lightning powers?
Maybe Luffy’s not the only rubber man after
all.
Pekoms was riddled with bullet holes and dropped
into shark infested waters.
Don’t worry, he’s alright, though.
And, the newest member of the club: Pound
- he inexplicably survives the attacks of
the Big Mom pirates.
The Will of P is the only force in One Piece
that can rival the might of the Will of D.
And this is why we’ll likely see our good
friend Pedro again in the near future.
**Blackbeard will kill Shanks**
We all know that Oda loves to make us cry.
Oda also loves giving Luffy one million reasons
to punch Blackbeard.
Blackbeard was largely responsible for Ace’s
death.
He’s the chief rival for Luffy’s ultimate
goal, the One Piece.
Blackbeard has captured Luffy’s good friend
Koby (and may do the same for his chief ally,
Law).
Moreover, they have different taste in pies
- a conflict that cannot be overcome by any
means other than violence.
We also know that Shanks and Blackbeard have
a history, having met each other all the way
back during childhood.
Blackbeard even gave Shanks his signature
scars.
It was ages and ages ago when we saw the series’
first meeting between Yonkou - when Shanks
went to Whitebeard to warn him about Teach’s
machinations.
I’m scared to even speak the words, so let’s
knock on wood as we say: Blackbeard might
kill Shanks.
He could even do so before Luffy is able to
reunite with him and return the straw hat.
It would likely be the most emotional moment
in the series to date, but it would definitely
make for the most satisfying smackdown in
manga history once Luffy took his revenge.
**Luffy’s execution**
A lot of classic tales are circular.
They end where they began and a story can
have a beautiful poetry to it when the author
uses this effect.
One Piece opens with the execution of the
pirate king, Gol D. Roger.
It could very well end with the execution
of the next pirate king.
If Roger’s death urged a new generation
of pirates to set out to sea, Luffy’s could
too.
Luffy is the type of person who wants to see
everyone in the world taste the freedom and
adventure of a life at sea.
As bittersweet as Luffy’s death could be,
it could also make for a beautiful ending
to the series.
**Caribou Baroque Works**
This is another theory by the YouTuber Randy
Troy.
Caribou, the swampiest character in One Piece,
has stumbled face first into some huge information
about the ancient weapons.
Information that he’s hinted he wants to
bring to a certain someone.
Prior to the Wano arc, it was thought he’d
trade this information to Big Mom or Kaidou,
but with them out of the picture, we’re
running out of options.
Teach is a prime candidate, but this theory
posits another major player in the New World:
Sir Crocodile of the Cross Guild.
The theory comes from the fact that Caribou
doesn’t look too far off from the concept
art of Mr. 10.
Mr. 10 was a Baroque Works member that was
mentioned by Vivi, but who we never actually
met in the series.
However, in Oda’s preliminary sketches of
the character, there are some similarities
to Caribou.
The face shape and generally wild hair are
pretty true to Caribou’s character design.
Is it possible that Caribou has been a former
underling of Crocodile all along?
After all, Crocodile’s initial goal in Alabasta
was to obtain the Ancient Weapon Pluton - and
now Caribou could help him finally succeed
in that mission.
**Emerald City**
When the Straw Hats first encountered Bellamy
the Hyena, he laughed them off for believing
in myths such as the City of Gold and the
One Piece.
In his list of ludicrous dreams, though, he
also mentioned an Emerald City.
The Straw Hats would soon encounter the City
of Gold in Skypiea and Whitebeard has taught
us that the One Piece is Real.
So, does Bellamy’s third entry, the Emerald
City, also exist?
Who’s to say Oda doesn’t have time left
in the final saga to shoehorn in a quick Wizard
of Oz inspired arc?
**Lurking Legend Gin**
At Jump Festa 2018, Oda hinted that a “Lurking
Legend” would appear in One Piece during
the Wano arc.
He also teased that this figure would be the
Straw Hats strongest opponent.
For years, fans have theorized on who this
Lurking Legend could be.
In fact, Wano came and went, and we’re still
not 100% clear on who the Lurking Legend was.
The most likely candidates are Imu-Sama or
Rocks D. Xebec, however, the fan community
has come up with some truly wild guesses.
Among these are Shiki the Golden Lion and
other super-powerful figures.
The wildest guess, though?
Gin - the former crewmate of Don Krieg who
the Straw Hats encountered during the Baratie
arc.
After all, Gin promised to meet our crew again
one day in the New World…and we’ve been
waiting ever since.
**Tier 5**
Woah.
We’re halfway there.
At this point we dare not leave our craft…at
least not if we don’t want to get the bends.
At this depth of fandom, the pressure of the
depths could crush us - just as the depths
of One Piece lore crush the minds of casual
fans.
**Koushiro is Denjiro**
Before we learned that Kyoshiro was actually
Denjiro after going through grudge-induced
plastic surgery, many fans noticed that the
Denjiro in Oden’s flashback looked a whole
lot like Koushiro.
Hold on - let’s flip back 1000 chapters
and remind ourselves who Koushiro is…especially
since that name is awfully similar to Kyoshiro
in the first place.
Koushiro is this guy - Zoro’s swordsmanship
teacher and Kuina’s father back from Shimotsuki
Village in the East Blue.
And I can understand why people would have
thought that this was a candidate for Denjiro’s
identity.
I mean, just look at him - he clearly just
looks like an older Denjiro.
And we know based on the Shimotsuki name that
Koushiro probably has some connection to Wano.
But leave it to Oda to surprise us with a
man so angry his face changed forever.
**Zoro Sharingan**
Zoro’s eye has been closed since the timeskip.
For some reason, he hasn’t been allowed
to wear a classic pirate eye patch, because
Oda is saving the eye patch for a very special
character at some point.
A lot of the fan base, though, presumably
people who have watched a lot of Naruto, think
that this eye can’t just be injured.
No - Zoro’s closed eye must be hiding an
amazing power-up.
Maybe he has a weird ringed eye like Mihawk.
Or maybe Zoro got so lost that he found himself
in the wrong series and ended up with a sharingan…or
a rinnegan…or a byakugan…man Naruto has
a lot of different kinds of eyes.
**The One Piece is destroying the Red Line**
I don’t know about you, but as a long time
member of the fan community, the legendary
Inherited Will theory is the first “mega-theory”
that I can remember reading.
Many other super-sized theories have come
after - huge, sprawling monoliths dedicated
to uncovering the greatest mysteries of the
series.
What is the One Piece?
What purpose do the ancient weapons serve?
What is the Will of D?
So many theories with mountains of evidence
have come, but one of the first, possibly
*the* first comprehensive and believable theory
was the Inherited Will Theory posted on the
Arlong Park Forums.
If you’re unfamiliar, you should definitely
read the theory in depth or watch one of the
many YouTube videos covering it, but a quick
version is this:The One Piece is destroying
the Red Line, literally combining the seas
of the world into “One Piece.”
It would likely take the power of the ancient
weapons to destroy this structure.
It would mean the end of Mariejois, and thus
it would fulfill Madame Sharly’s prediction
of destroying Fishman Island below it.
And it would allow for many of the Straw Hats’
dreams to come true at once.
Nami would be free to sail around the world
and map it.
Combining the seas would create the All Blue
for Sanji.
Brook would be reunited with Laboon.
The list goes on.
Having the theory in brief here does it a
disservice, so again, if you’re unfamiliar
make sure to check out this theory.
You won’t regret it.
**People in snowy countries don’t sleep**
On Drum Island, when Luffy is taking a sick
Nami to Dr. Kureha, he tells Sanji a rumor
he heard once.
He asks Sanji if he knew that people in snowy
countries don’t sleep - stating that if
they do, they’ll die.
Curiously enough, in a classic turn of Oda’s
god-tier foreshadowing, Drum Island was the
first arc in which we heard of Blackbeard.
Yes, we first saw Marshall D. Teach on Jaya,
but Dalton of Drum Kingdom states that their
kingdom was attacked by the Blackbeard Pirates
which is why Wapol flees with his legion of
doctors in the first place.
Luffy probably heard the rumor about people
in snowy countries from Shanks, who knew Blackbeard
as a child.
Likely, the rumor isn’t about people from
winter islands, but about Blackbeard himself,
who’s speculated to never sleep.
A young Shanks and Buggy may have taken this
combined with the fact that Teach is from
a Winter Island to concoct the rumor that
Luffy would repeat in Drum Island - setting
us up for an eventual payoff when it came
to Blackbeard.
**The D is a half moon**What could the D in
stand for?
Gol D. Roger.
Monkey D. Luffy.
Jaguar D. Saul.
All of these natural enemies of God have an
initial in common, but one theory suggests…what
if this initial didn’t stand for a name
at all?
Maybe it’s not Dream or Dawn or anything,
but it’s a pictogram.
Maybe that D is actually a half moon.
We know that moons are important in the series.
Enel is chilling on one.
The Celestial Dragons and winged races are
probably from one.
The moon causes the minks’ sulong transformation.
So it wouldn’t be that crazy for the D clan
to also have a connection to the ever-important
moons of One Piece.
Perhaps it’s so important to them that it’s
in their very name.
**Sanji is dead**
We’re not just talking about his fashion
sense after stepping through Vegapunk’s
style changer.
Back during the Zou arc, there was a ravenous,
bloodthirsty contingent of the fanbase who
were convinced that Sanji was dead.
Let’s look at the facts: Nami and the rest
of the crew didn’t want to talk about what
had happened to Sanji, but he was clearly
absent during the arc.
Then we found out that Sanji was wanted by
a Yonkou.
And this was the first time we’d come face
to face with a yonkou.
Big Mom, after all, in her first introduction,
was shown to be a cannibal.
This was the early post time-skip and people
saw signs of a darker and harsher series.
From the brutality of Doflamingo to seeming
willingness of Oda to kill off characters
(compared to pre-timeskip) as evidence with
villains like Vergo and Monet, things were
looking more violent.
Some fans took this to mean that maybe he’d
turn the story upside down by having us lose
a member of the crew.
People also saw his Only Alive wanted poster
designation as a potential misdirection.
Thankfully this theory was very wrong and
our shitty cook is still kicking.
**Time Travel Training Montage**
This theory belongs to the “Raid Will Fail”
family of theories.
It’s very odd how little we know about Toki.
We know she’s from the Void Century and
therefore is a well spring of important knowledge,
and yet, after her sacrifice in Oden’s Castle,
we never hear from her again.
However, since she flung the retainers forward
in time, it seemed that perhaps she had jumped
forward in time as well.
When things were at their most bleak for the
alliance in the war against Kaidou and Big
Mom, this theory stated that Toki would appear
again and would once again fling our fighters
to buy them more time to prepare against the
Yonkou.
Luffy seemed out of his element, especially
before he unlocked advanced conqueror’s
haki and Gear 5th.
How could he possibly beat Kaidou without
more time to train and prepare?
Well, by doing the same thing that Kinemon
and the others did, by going forward in time
some undisclosed amount so that he could train
further and fight Kaidou another day.
**Vegapunk Alien**
Dr. Vegapunk has created the wildest technological
marvels of the One Piece world.
He’s created artificial devil fruits, weather
control systems, the pacifista, and more.
How could one scientific genius make so many
amazing inventions?
Aliens [Show the ancient aliens guy].
We already know that aliens in the form of
space pirates and possibly the winged races
exist.
So perhaps Vegapunk is a long lost member
of an advanced interstellar civilization introducing
his peoples’ technologies to the Blue Sea.
**Two Piece**
What comes after the One Piece?
The Two Piece, of course.
This in-joke in the fandom states that after
the final chapter closes One Piece, Two Piece
will begin serialization.
After all, why would Shonen Jump let their
biggest property rest when they could keep
making those sweet stacks of pirate cash.
Just as Naruto was followed by Boruto, following
Naruto’s son, One Piece will be followed
by Two Piece, then Three Piece, and so on,
and so on, until the inevitable heat death
of the universe.
**Sniper Island**
Where is Sniper Island?
If Sogeking is to be believed, it’s in your
heart.
However, we all know that Usopp’s lies have
a tendency to come true, as explored on a
previous tier of the iceberg.
What if Sniper Island really is a place in
the Grand Line?
What if there’s an actual Sniper King who
Usopp will either learn from or have to go
toe-to-toe with?
Listen, I know we’re expecting a giant sized
arc one day in Elbaf - after all, we’d love
to get more closure on Big Mom’s story arc
as well as see what our favorite giants like
Dorry, Brogy, and Hajrudin are all up to,
but perhaps it’s not Elbaf where Usopp will
become a brave warrior of the sea, but Sniper
Island itself.
**Carrot is the Traitor**
In retrospect, it seemed obvious that Kanjuro
was the traitor.
In Kabuki plays, after all, the artist archetype
is often cast as a villain or betrayer.
His design itself was the biggest clue as
to his true allegiances.
However, while we did know there was a traitor
- someone who was feeding information such
as the whereabouts of Zou to the Beast Pirates
- that didn’t stop the fan community from
making all kinds of guesses.
One of the wildest?
That Carrot - new leader of Zou and Straw
Hat in our hearts - was the traitor.
She was sneaky enough to infiltrate the Thousand
Sunny, after all.
And she was mysteriously absent from a lot
of the proceedings on Wano - suspicious much?
Turns out, though, she wasn’t a spy - she
was just sort of…done being plot relevant.
**TIER 6**
I can’t remember what light looks like.
I can’t remember my own name or the faces
of my family.
At this depth, all there is is One Piece…*with
incredible enthusiasm* On to Tier 6!
**Pell 9/11**
Pell did 9/11.
Wait, wrong notes.
Pell is alive because of 9/11.
At the end of Alabasta, Pell made the ultimate
sacrifice in saving everyone from Crocodile’s
bomb.
However, it just so happened that this chapter
came out right around the same time as the
September 11, 2001 terrorist attack on the
Twin Towers in the United States.
Rumor has it that Shonen Jump editors thought
it was in bad taste to have a character killed
in a terrorist attack so close to this event,
and thus, the Will of P was born.
**Kaidou in the Colosseum**
In the D Block of the Corrida Colosseum, there
was a participant named Meadows.
He wore a large leopard skin as a hood and
cape.
He had a rather “beastly” appearance,
in fact.
Since all we knew of Kaidou was that he was
the King of Beasts, one short lived theory
was that this participant was in fact Kaidou
in disguise.
After all, at that point, all we’d seen
of the Yonkou was a retconned silhouette that
ended up looking nothing like Kaidou’s actual
appearance…but did share some similarities
with Meadows.
However, once Meadows and the rest of Block
D were taken out by Hakuba, this theory didn’t
have a leg to stand on.
Unless there were a few big Meadows stans
arguing that Cavendish was Yonkou level, of
course.
**Straw Hat Smoker**
Who will be the next Straw Hat?
It was a huge debate all throughout Wano.
Would Carrot join the crew?
Would Momo or Tama come along as a cabin boy
or girl?
Would Yamato join?
Well, Oda played us all.
It was no one!
I mean, we technically got Jinbe properly
joining the crew during Wano, but that was
a foregone conclusion since way back in Fishman
Island.
Though…we’re still wondering how he got
away from Whole Cake Island in one piece…
Some theorists are looking forward to try
to predict who will join up next.
And some guy [Show Mr. Morj] thinks that Smoker
will become a Straw Hat by the end of the
series.
The idea goes that Smoker joining the Straw
Hats would represent the ultimate merging
between the Marines and the Straw Hats - Smoker’s
personal journey is all about finding justice…and
this would mean he’d finally realize that
it’s not the World Government, but the Straw
Hats that are truly on the side of justice.
The question is: Will this man’s pride ever
allow him to call himself a pirate?
**Charlotte Nami**
Fun fact: We still don’t know who Nami’s
Mommy is.
I mean, her real mom will always be Bellmere,
but her birth mom is unknown.
And back in the first half of the series I
would have said it doesn’t even matter who
Nami’s mom is.
But let’s look at the facts: Luffy is the
son of the world’s most wanted man and the
grandson of the hero of the marines.
Zoro is definitely somehow related to the
former Daimyo of Ringo, Shimotsuki Ushimaru.
Sanji is a literal prince of the Germa Kingdom.
Usopp’s father is a member of a Yonkou crew.
Are you starting to see a pattern?
It’s not unlikely that Nami will follow
in the footsteps of the other East Blue crew
members and have some kind of significant
lineage.
But who is she related to?
It’s almost certainly not Big Mom, but this
was a big theory back before and in the early
days of the Whole Cake Island arc.
But if not Big Mom, then who?
Well, maybe we’ll find out in a later iceberg
entry.
**The blond Gorosei is Sanji’s Dad**
In my heart of hearts, part of me still wishes
this theory had turned out to be true.
As soon as Sanji’s wanted poster at the
end of Dressrosa was revealed to have an Only
Alive status, the gears were turning in the
community to figure out what was so special
about Sanji.
People had long thought he was important due
to little hints like his Mr. Prince identity,
but now it was looking like our suspicions
were confirmed.
The primary suspect?
One of the Gorosei, the tall blond one with
the goatee, looks a hell of a lot like he
could be related to Sanji.
And as one of the highest powers in the world,
he definitely would have had the power to
influence the wanted posters - after all,
we didn’t know about the Vinsmokes yet.
And as much as we love our evil power rangers,
the Germa Kingdom, Judge…doesn’t really
look like he’s related to Sanji other than
the blond hair.
Hey, if the Gorosei are as old as we think
they are, maybe there’s still hope that
the blond Gorosei is Sanji’s great great
great great great great grandpa!
**Shakky was on the Rocks Crew**
Our favorite Sabaody bartender and Rayleigh
life partner, Shakky, retired from piracy
decades ago.
However, we knew she was a major player in
the pirate world at some point.
In the story’s detour to Amazon Lily after
Wano, we learned that she was actually the
the former leader of the Kuja Pirates before
Boa Hancock.
In retrospect, it makes perfect sense and
explains why Rayleigh has such a close knit
relationship with the residents of Amazon
Lily.
However, before this reveal, the prevailing
theory was that Shakky was actually a member
of the Rocks pirates.
After all, every other significant pirate
like Whitebeard, Big Mom, Kaidou, and Shiki
were, so why not add one more member?
Also, it would give Rayleigh and Shakky’s
romance a little bit of a “forbidden fruit”
twist - a real Romeo and Juliet flair.
But no, Amazon Lily it was, and we’re more
than satisfied with that reveal.
**Celestial dragons are aliens**
Let’s just look at the facts: #1: “Celestial”
has two definitions.
It can mean “heavenly or mythical”, or
more literally, it can just mean space stuff
- the sun, the moon, the stars - all of these
are “celestial bodies.”
#2: These clowns wear space suits.
And sure, they justify the giant fish bowls
on their heads by saying they don’t want
to breathe the same air as commoners.
However, that doesn’t change the fact that
the rest of their fashion looks very outer
space chic.
#3: As we’ve discussed on previous iceberg
entries already, we already have confirmed
aliens in One Piece, so what’s a few more?
The more the merrier, I say.
Space Pirates?
Skypieans?
Lunarians?
And the Dragons!
**Oars was Joyboy**
We may have already met the original Joyboy,
albeit in a roundabout way.
Luffy seems to be Joyboy reincarnated - they
share a spirit, a dream, a soul, and even
a devil fruit.
However, they also may have shared a shadow
at one point.
On Thriller Bark, the Straw Hat crew had a
tag-team fight against the massive zombie,
Oars, a member of the Ancient Oni race.
It would be all too fitting if the zombie
that received Luffy’s shadow from Moria,
just so happened to be the previous incarnation
of Joyboy.
We do know, after all, that the previous Joyboy
was likely a giant of some kind - the frozen
straw hat beneath Mariejois is the biggest
clue for this.
The biggest wrench in this idea is the timeline.
The void century, around when Joyboy was purported
to live was 800 years before the current story,
but Oars lived about 500 years ago.
However, who knows how effective Moria’s
carbon dating is?
With as much historical manipulation as the
World Government gets up to, this discrepancy
could probably be brushed off by Oda.
**Akainu is the leader of SWORD**
Akainu is a despicable marine who has killed
innocent people and his fair share of Aces.
Okay, well, one Ace.
He is ruthless and will seek out any means
necessary to fulfill his idea of justice.
SWORD is a secret organization within the
Marines that runs counter to the wishes of
the World Government.
Notable members include Koby, who actively
defied Akainu during the Paramount War and
would have ended up thoroughly melted if it
weren’t for Shanks stepping in at the last
second.
Akainu and SWORD seem diametrically opposed.
But have you considered this cover page that
shows Akainu shirtless?
What is that tattoo on his shoulder?
No, not the tribal one - his other shoulder:
That’s right, a SWORD.
Therefore he must be the leader…of SWORD.
Hey, I mean, a guy who takes care of bonsai
trees must have a secret soft side, right?
**Shanks Haki Fruit**
Shanks has never been seen to use a devil
fruit.
In fact, there’s a very prominent scene
in Chapter 1 of Shanks swimming.
Now, could he have theoretically eaten a fruit
in the meantime between Luffy’s backstory
and the current story?
Sure, but Shanks’ whole crew seems to be
made up of non-Haki users.
Otherwise, it seems like we would have seen
at least one power so far.What we have seen
Shanks make some crazy displays of is his
Haki.
Arguably, he showed us Conqueror’s Haki
in the very first chapter when he scared off
the Lord of the Coast.
He also split the sky in his confrontation
with Whitebeard.
But most recently, he forced Aramaki out of
his logia transformation and got him to back
off of the Scabbards from miles away at sea
off the coast of Wano - and he did so with
nothing but a long distance bolt of Conqueror’s
Haki.
This is easily the wildest feat of Haki we’ve
seen in the series.
For a long time, even before his awesome recent
feat, this crazy theory has speculated that
Shanks’ use of Haki IS a devil fruit: that
Shanks is a Haki Man who ate the Haki-Haki
no Mi.
Granted, this theory was first conceived before
we had much understanding of Haki and is extremely
unlikely.
But did you click on an iceberg video to get
sane, rational theories?
No, you’re here for the wildest stuff possible!
**CP0 are Big Mom’s childhood friends**
Big Mom’s backstory was one of the most
shocking and gruesome moments in the entire
series.
Sure, we’ve dealt with slavery, prejudice,
corrupt governments, and more.
But one thing we never thought we’d see
in One Piece?
Cannibalism.
So imagine our surprise when we were treated
to Big Mom eating the worst birthday feast
of all time in the form of all of her friends.
But hear me out: What if…she didn’t eat
all of them?
Eagle-eyed viewers noticed that a couple CP0
members who were present at the Raid on Onigashima
somewhat resembled two of the orphans from
Mother Carmel’s orphanage who grew up alongside
Charlotte Lin Lin.
This theory seemed to make total sense.
Firstly, the CP0 members all wear masks.
When a character is masked, it seems logical
that they’re hiding their identity for some
reason - as if it would be a big reveal when
they are unmasked.
So some of us expected to know some of the
CP0 characters.
After all, some other CP0 members turned out
to be familiar faces like Lucci and Kaku.
It also makes sense because Mother Carmel
was known to sell orphans to the Marines,
so if these two survived Big Mom’s birthday
party, it would make sense for them to end
up as operatives for the World Government.
And on top of it all, since Big Mom was present
at the raid, they could play perfectly into
developing her story further.
After all, we still haven’t had a chance
to see her reckon with the truth of her past,
but we’ve seen flags foretelling it will
happen - such as her daughter Pudding having
a memory fruit.
Having left Wano, it seems like this theory
is dead in the water, but it will still live
on in our head canon.
**Done Piece**
Done Piece…why does that sound familiar?
Wait a minute, that’s a theory that I’m
known for!
If you know my channel, you might have seen
“The Best One Piece Theory Ever, I Guess”
- where I adapt this theory from Japanese
YouTuber Yuderon.
Now, it takes a solid half hour to explain
fully, but here’s the gist: The original
map of Jaya looks like a giant skull.
The City of Gold in Skypiea was located in
the skull’s right eye.
But its left eye is empty.
The theory?
The One Piece was this missing left eye and
currently resides…at the bottom of the strange
hole beneath Enies Lobby.
**Ancient Weapon Vivi**
Crocodile’s master plan in Alabasta wasn’t
simply to take over the desert country.
His actual ambition was to obtain one of the
Ancient Weapons, particularly the battleship,
Pluton which was rumored to lay beneath the
country.
Nowadays, we know that Pluton is actually
beneath Wano, but what if Alabasta was part
of the puzzle of the Ancient Weapons.
In fact, what if he had one of the Ancient
Weapons within arm’s reach all along?
This theory states that Vivi herself is an
ancient weapon.
It picked up steam after the Fishman Island
arc, when all of our previous notions of what
an ancient weapon could be were shattered
when we found out that the mermaid princess,
Shirahoshi, was Poseidon.
Just as Shirahoshi can command the Sea Kings,
perhaps Vivi is also the conduit by which
some force of nature - either Pluton or Uranus
is operated.
In a dark twist, with Vivi now missing…could
Imu be using her as a key to utilize the destructive
power of Uranus?
**TIER 7**
We’ve nearly reached the bottom.
Down here there is only darkness.
Darkness and One Piece theories.
Oh, and those weird messed-up looking kind
of fish.
But mostly just darkness and One Piece theories.
Theories like…
**One Piece is on the Moon**
A large portion of the fanbase hopes that
much like Gamestock Stonks, the Straw Hats
are going to the moon!
Sure, Enel could come back to wreak havoc
on the Blue Sea, but surely Dr. Vegapunk has
a spare spacecraft laying around Egghead Island.
There are plenty of mysteries revolving around
the moon - some of which we already alluded
to on a previous tier of the iceberg.
What better way to explore the origin of the
Lunarians and the other winged races than
to go straight to the source?
After all, Laugh Tale is ludicrously hard
to reach - something has to be preventing
sailors from just happening on it by chance.
Sure, it could be terrible storms or something
- but how cool would it be if it were actually
outer space itself preventing the average
pirate from reaching the One Piece?
**Shichibukai 7 deadly sins**
There are seven warlords.
And ever since Fullmetal Alchemist named their
homunculi after the seven deadly sins, every
group of characters featuring seven members
has been theorized as being representative
of those sins.
Unfortunately, while there are some good comparisons
within the group…the analogy kind of falls
apart if you think about it for too long.
The clearest analogues are probably Boa Hancock
as Lust and Gecko Moria as Sloth.
Hancock because her powers rely on people
being infatuated with her and Moria because
he gave up ambitions of traveling the New
World and traded them for building a zombie
army to do his dirty work for him.
Doflamingo and Crocodile could probably be
Pride and Greed…but what members of the
Shichibukai *aren’t* prideful and greedy?
I mean, they’re pirates.
It kind of comes with the territory.
Wrath and Envy are where things really fall
apart.
Jinbe could *maybe* be wrathful because…he’s
angry sometimes?
But really, he’s usually a pretty chill
dude.
What is Kuma envious of?
Having free will?
Who knows?
While it’s fun to speculate about, the Seven
Deadly Warlords just don’t really hold up
to scrutiny?
**Nami will control Uranus**
Nami is One Piece’s #1 meteorologist.
Thanks to tools like the Clima-Tact, the technology
of Weatheria, and now Big Mom’s homie Zeus,
Nami has formidable weather-based powers.
But how could they become even more powerful?
What will Nami’s final upgrade be?
According to this theory, it’ll be the Ancient
Weapon Uranus itself.
Now, the only real evidence - if you can call
it that - is that Uranus is a God of the Sky
and weather…also comes from the sky.
Unfortunately for Nami, recent events would
suggest that it’s actually Imu who controls
this powerful weapon.
At least if that’s what we assume the giant
sky laser to be.
**Christianity exists in One Piece**
Sorry, Enel, but in One Piece there are plenty
of Gods ready to dethrone you.
Obviously we have things like Sengoku’s
Golden Buddha fruit and Luffy being compared
to the Wisdom King or the Sun God Nika.
But apparently there are plenty of One Piece
characters who believe in and worship the
Christian God?
The implications of this have not been explored
in the story, but Kuma is clearly carrying
around a Bible, the Christian holy book.
We’ve also got the cultists who were trying
to worship Satan, but ended up with Brook
instead.
We have references like the Adam and Eve trees.
And all of this begs the question: Is there
a One Piece Jesus?
**Rocks is Imu**
What if Rocks hadn’t been defeated at God
Valley?
What if he actually did fulfill his goal of
conquering the world by reaching the Empty
Throne and claiming it for himself?
This theory was especially popularized by
Artur - The Library of Ohara’s fan comic
the Return to Reverie, which explored an alternate
idea of what could have occurred after the
Reverie arc.
It sees Imu uncovering himself as Rocks and
doing battle against the Revolutionary Army.
If you haven’t read it, I highly recommend
it because it’s super well made.
It’s so professionally done that they look
like real chapters.
**Fire Festival Ghosts**
This one was a huge part of Joyboy Theories
Wano arc agenda.
In Japan, the tradition of holding a fire
festival often connects to the idea of sending
off spirits or reconnecting with ancestors.
The thought was that the Fire Festival could
literally see ghosts of past characters manifest
during the raid.
At various points in the arc, characters impersonated
characters long thought dead.
Kanjuro created a fake Oden.
Black Maria created an illusion of Robin’s
mother and Professor Clover.
This theory said that these characters and
more could come back to create some very emotional
moments in which flashback characters could
see how much the Straw Hats have grown.
And Oden appearing would have truly struck
fear into Kaidou.
Add this to the list of theories that we’re
a little bit sad didn’t happen.
**Snow bunny carrot**
In Punk Hazard, we learned that when a devil
fruit user dies, the fruit reincarnates into
a nearby piece of normal fruit.
After Smiley the Doomsday Axolotl died, a
random nearby fruit turned into the Axolotl
zoan.
However, Smiley wasn’t the only devil fruit
user to die on Punk Hazard.
Monet, the snow fruit user, also died.
Now, we’re not sure about Punk Hazard’s
fruit reserves, but we do know that the Thousand
Sunny happens to have a few of Nami’s orange
trees growing on it.
The thought behind this theory was that Monet’s
snow logia would have jumped into one of these
oranges to be unwittingly eaten by someone
on the Straw Hat ship.
A prime suspect for this after Zou was none
other than Carrot.
After the Sunny sailed away from Punk Hazard,
a strange panel featured a bunch of bunnies
depicted in the waves beneath the ship, which
was thought to be foreshadowing of the Snow
Bunny Carrot.
**Evil Shanks**
What if Shanks…but evil?
Even though Shanks’s presence has loomed
over the series since the very first chapter,
we know shockingly little about his actual
motivations.
We know he’s wildly powerful - able to stop
the Paramount War with a single sentence - and
we now know that he’s making his move to
claim the One Piece.
We also know that he stole the Gomu Gomu no
Mi from the World Government…and might have
known that it was much more than met the eye.
We also know that he can seek an audience
with the Gorosei at his own whim.
All of these details add up to make a super
mysterious character.
And as Luffy’s hero, we’ve always thought
of him as a great man.
But could there be a darker side to this emperor
of the sea?
Could he be orchestrating events in the series
for his own purposes?
**Seastone Sandals**
The year is 2008.The arc is Sabaody archipelago.
The One Piece fanbase would not yet know the
wonders of Haki.
Logias were nigh unstoppable because of their
intangibility and there was seemingly no way
to overcome them unless you had a natural
counter.
The only ways we’d seen logias be defeated
before are when Luffy used water to defeat
Crocodile and when he resisted Enel’s lightning
powers with his rubber body.
However, there was one exception.
Seastone.
Smoker’s seastone Jutte had been seen to
incapacitate devil fruit users and seastone
handcuffs or jail cells could keep them captive.
So when we saw Dark King Rayleigh stop Kizaru,
a man made of light, with just a kick…the
fan base jumped to some conclusions.
Obviously the key to his stopping the Admiral
was in his footwear - his Kairoseki Sandals.
**Pangea Kingdom**
The base of operations for the world government
is in Pangea Castle.
This idea states that Pangea Castle is actually
named for the Ancient Kingdom itself.
After the kingdom fell, the World Government
took its place and took up residence in Pangea
Castle.
Moreover, Pangea Castle, which sits upon the
Red Line, is named for the super continent
which once existed on Earth, before the tectonic
movement separated the world into the seven
continents we know today.
The theory goes that such a continent may
have existed in the One Piece world, before
the world was separated into many islands
and scattered across the sea with the only
continent remaining being the Red Line.
**Mihawk Homie**
In the beginning of the Whole Cake Island
arc, we received the revelation that Big Mom
wielded the Soul Soul Fruit.
This fruit filled her island to the brim with
all sorts of whimsical creatures who were
imbued with part of her soul - the trees,
the food, and more were transformed into beings
called homies.
We also learned that as a tax for living in
Whole Cake Island, a small portion of each
citizen’s soul was taken each year to empower
the emperor.
When we learned about her soul manipulation
abilities, the community was abuzz trying
to figure out the implications of this ability.
Particularly, one homie named the Crane Rider
Randolph, a gallant rabbit warrior, made some
viewers curious.
They noticed some surface-level similarities
between Randolph and the warlord Dracule Mihawk
and speculated that Randolph may have held
a portion of the Shichibukai’s soul.
**Pandaman Guardian Angel**
There is a special force watching over the
world of One Piece: the Pandaman.
This Easter Egg character has been hidden
in tons of chapters all throughout the series
- he’s practically omnipresent.
It can’t be a mere coincidence that he’s
hiding in the panels of so many chapters,
seemingly following the Straw Hats around
on their adventures.
Perhaps he’s more than an Easter Egg and
this Panda-headed hero is actually the Straw
Hats’ Guardian Angel.
**Jango Power-Up**
In Syrup Village, one member of the Kuro pirates
was Jango the hypnotist.
At one point, he hypnotized members of his
own crew to increase their strength when they
went up against the Straw Hats.
However, as a gag, Luffy was also hypnotized
and started rampaging.
This theory suggests that Luffy’s insane
strength throughout the series is all thanks
to Jango’s hypnotism.
In fact, Luffy is still hypnotized even now.
It’s not just his will or his devil fruit
- he refuses to ever give up no matter how
many times he’s beaten because he’s literally
compelled to do so.
**TIER 8**
Avast mateys.
We’re finally here - 20,000 leagues under
the One Piece sea.
I never thought we’d make it.
The submarine is out of rations and I’m
afraid I’m not long for this world.
But at least before I go, we get to explore
the most absurd One Piece theories of all
time.
**Kaidou is a Poneglyph**
You heard me.
Kaidou is a poneglyph.
At least that’s what some people used to
think.
All we knew about the fearsome Kaidou, the
world’s strongest creature, is that he was
night indestructible.
Nothing could harm this beast.
You know what else is indestructible?
Poneglyphs.
Therefore, the only logical conclusion…is
that Kaidou was a poneglyph that ate the ancient
oni fruit.
**Devil Fruits are People**
We’ve already had more cannibalism in One
Piece than in the average story (which…you
know, not a high bar to cross, but still…).
However, as we learn the secrets of the Ancient
Kingdom, it might be the case that One Piece
gets a Soylent Green level twist.
That’s right - Devil Fruits are made of
people.
We’ve seen some possible evidence of past
users’ wills or memories or personalities
being embedded into fruits.
And it’s unclear whether fruits might impact
the users’ personalities.
Is Luffy emblematic of freedom because he
ate the fruit, or did he eat the fruit because
he’s emblematic of freedom?
Same with Doflamingo being manipulative and
controlling and so-on and so-on.
So, were devil fruits possibly created from
people who happened to have these abilities?
And were their personalities or souls passed
along with them??
**Imu D. Nami**
As we discussed back when we talked about
Nami possibly being Big Mom’s child, this
theory is also predicated on the idea that
we don’t know who Nami’s birth parents
are.
So let’s just get crazy with it: Nami is
Imu’s daughter.
And let’s throw on the D initial just for
good measure.
This would make for a Darth Vader level twist,
and hey, if she joins up with her pops, maybe
he’ll let her control the ancient weapon
Uranus after all!
It’s a win-win (other than the islands that
are obliterated off the map).
**Sanji is Uranus**
Okay, hear me out.
Back in the day, minds were blown when we
found out that Shirahoshi was Poseidon.
We had no idea that an ancient weapon being
a person was even a possibility.
The mermaid princess is big, but she’s no
warship.
So suddenly everything was on the table and
the fanbase was wracking our collective brain
to figure out which characters could be other
ancient weapons.
Conveniently, around this same time on Fishman
Island, Sanji had just revealed his Sky Walk
ability.
And Uranus is a God of the Sky…ergo…Sanji
is Uranus.
Simple as that, really.
**Kuina is Mihawk**
Kuina is Tashigi?
Broke.
Kuina is Mihawk.
Woke.
Obviously Kuina didn’t fall down the stairs
- that would be such an unceremonious death.
Clearly what actually happened is that Kuina
left with the Revolutionaries when Dragon
docked at Shimotsuki when Zoro was still a
child.
She was always told growing up that as a girl,
she could never become the world’s greatest
swordsman.
Therefore, she asked Ivankov to perform a
sex change on her.
Afterward, taking on the new name Dracule
Mihawk, he became the world’s greatest swordsman.
**The One Piece is in Barto’s Briefcase**
In the Corrida Colosseum, when we first met
Bartolomeo, he was carrying a mysterious briefcase
chained to his wrist.
There was a panel that focused heavily on
this briefcase, suggesting that it was very
important.
The briefcase was never mentioned or seen
again.
Obviously, we can logically conclude that
its contents were none other than the One
Piece.
Barto had found it in order to make an offering
to Luffy so that he could make his hero the
king of the pirates.
However, he was so starstruck when he met
the straw hats that he promptly forgot all
about it and left the briefcase in Dressrosa.
**Koby Final Boss**
The first marine Luffy met on his journey
(not counting his childhood guardian, Garp)
was Koby, the pink-haired cabin boy of the
Alvida pirates.
Luffy has a dream to become the pirate king
and Koby has a dream to become a Marine Admiral.
And while these two have been allies and friends
throughout the series, their two goals are
diametrically opposed.
A truly wild twist to the series would be
instead of Luffy going up against someone
like Akainu, would be to go up against one
of his oldest friends in a clash of ideals.
Koby would need one hell of a powerup to contend
with the future pirate king, but it would
be a memorable ending for sure.
**Big Mom NHC10 Addict**
We all know that Big Mom has some serious
hunger pangs, but so do all the no-so-little
kids that the crew rescue from Punk Hazard.
That’s a pretty strange coincidence that
these seemingly unrelated characters both
suffer from the same condition.
However, there are a few connections between
them.
Big Mom had contracted Caesar Clown to do
work for her and he was also the one who was
performing gigantification experiments on
the children.
The children’s hunger pangs and subsequent
terrible rampages were due to withdrawal from
an addictive drug called NHC10.
He fed this drug to the children by hiding
it in candies, much like the sweet treats
that Big Mom often eats.
Big Mom is also, notably, giant compared to
a normal human.
Was she a failed experiment before being dropped
off on Elbaf?
Is she, too, an NHC10 addict who is consistently
feeling some major withdrawal symptoms?
**Oda is Pro-Monarchy**
One would think that with story features like
the Revolutionary Army and Luffy’s general
opposition to authority and declaring war
on the World Government, that Oda is very
against authoritarian regimes.
However, that’s not true at all.
Oda seemingly loves kingdoms with one central
authority, a monarch, so long as they have
a very nice king or queen instead of an evil
ruler.
From Vivi, to Shirahoshi, to Rebecca, the
Straw Hats love their monarchs - it’s just
when it’s a pirate or Wapol in charge that
this system of government really falls apart.
**Rockstar is Rocks**
Rocks D. Xebec was a scourge upon the One
Piece world, striking fear into the hearts
of the World Government and other pirates
alike.
Rockstar is a rookie who somehow landed a
spot on Shanks’ crew.
Observant viewers will realize that the name
“Rockstar” has “Rocks” right in it.
Coincidence?
I think not.
Is it not possible that Rocks did not die,
but simply waited and bided his time until
his old rival Roger passed away?
And since Shanks is very likely a Celestial
Dragon who was found on God Valley, he’s
likely just waiting for his chance to take
out God Valley’s last survivor.
**Zoro Bounty Hunter Long Con**
When Luffy recruits Roronoa Zoro, the swordsman
laughs him off.
After all, he was literally known as Pirate
Hunter Zoro.
He was one of the most infamous bounty hunters
in the East Blue.
This theory says that Zoro’s membership
in the crew is actually a long con.
He may seem like the most unwaveringly loyal
crew mate.
However, in actuality, he protects Luffy at
all costs because Luffy is his prey.
After all, Luffy’s paltry bounty at the
beginning of the series is nothing.
However, if Luffy can achieve his dream of
becoming the Pirate King, he’ll have the
highest bounty ever known - and once Zoro
brings him into the marines, he’ll be set
for life.
**Void Century Bonney**
Uh oh, this theory’s not looking too good
lately now that we’re in the Egghead Island
arc.
We’ve learned that in actuality, Bonney
is Kuma’s daughter and is learning about
the Void Century along with the rest of the
Straw Hats from Vegapunk.
However, just as it was once speculated that
she was related to Big Mom, her true age has
always been a pressing question.
If she can manipulate her age at will, it
seemed possible that she could be much, much
older than she let on.
Like…Void Century old, which could have
explained what Blackbeard wanted with her.
However, now it seems that her preferred age
is simply her actual one.
**Gaimon is the One Piece**
I lied earlier when I said that One Piece
was the friends we made along the way or it
was the Straw Hat or it was on the Moon or
in Bartolomeo’s Briefcase.
Obviously the REAL One Piece is not the friends
we made along the way - it was one specific
friend we made along the way: Gaimon.
Think about it for more than a second and
it becomes obvious.
First off - he’s on the Island of Rare Animals.
What else is rare?
The One Piece.
Secondly - Gaimon is in what?
A treasure chest.
And what is the One Piece?
A Treasure.
Oda couldn’t have foreshadowed this revelation
any harder.
Checkmate, theorists.
**End**
That was enough iceberg to sink Ten Titanic
Captains, but against all odds we made it
through together.
Whether our sanity is still in tact is up
for debate.
But that iceberg couldn’t stop us because
DREAMS WILL NEVER DIE.
Zehahahaha.[Blackbeard Laugh] If you need
another one hour video, you can watch my mega
wano analysis here.